okay good so um the title of the talk is
uh sketching for m estimators a unified
approach to robust regression
uh this is joint work with uh ken
clarkson
okay so um the regression problem in
this talk we're just going to look at
linear regression
which is a statistical method to study
linear dependencies
between variables in the presence of
noise a very simple example here is
ohm's law the voltage is the resistance
times the current
and we get a bunch of voltage current
uh pairs and we're trying to learn this
line that best fits them
the unknown resistance and throughout
the talk we'll see uh
various uh definitions of uh fitness
and um
okay so yeah so in the standard setting
you have uh one measured variable b
which was the voltage on the previous
slide and a set of predictor variables
a1 through ad
on the previous slide d was equal to one
and it was just the current
and the assumption is that b and the
variables a i
are linearly related okay up to some
noise
so what we have is that b is equal to
x naught plus a 1 x 1 plus dot a d
x d uh plus epsilon where epsilon is
some noise which may be
um stochastic or it may be worst case
and we're trying to learn these unknown
coefficients uh
x naught through x d by a standard
transformation we can assume this free
term
um x naught is equal to zero
and now when we see n observations of
this measured variable we can just write
this
in matrix form so we're given an n by d
matrix a
and the vector b um a is of
um so n is the number of observations d
the number of predictor variables
and when you write it like this the goal
is just to find a vector x in rd
so that a times x and b are close under
some notion of closeness
okay and um
throughout the talk we'll consider the
over constrained case when n is much
larger than d
we have many more examples okay so we
have a um
a very tall thin matrix a
um okay so what is what are some common
notions of closeness so probably the
most
uh used is the least squares method
where you try to find this d dimensional
vector
x that minimizes the euclidean distance
between a x and b
okay and the optimal solution there is
just the projection of b
onto the span of the columns of a
and this has certain desirable
statistical properties for instance if
the noise that you're adding
is um is id gaussian then this is an mle
this is yeah the mle for this problem
another nice property is it has a closed
form
solution so if the columns of a are
linearly independent
then you can just write down the optimal
solution
as um a transpose a inverse times a
transpose b
okay and similarly if the columns are
not linearly independent you can write
down the solution
in terms of the pseudo inverse of a
okay what's another fitness measure
that's used
so one is l1 regression and here the
only difference is you're trying to find
the vector x
that minimizes the l1 distance between a
x and b
okay the sum of absolute values of
differences
on the coordinates okay and this is
sometimes used uh because the cost is
intuitively less sensitive to outliers
than these squares
right because um you're not squaring the
distance
uh you're you're just summing up the
distances so you're not trying to fit
the
sort of outlying distances as much as
you would for the least squares solution
and you can set up this problem as a
linear program and also solve this
in polynomial time
okay so those are two examples but what
about the many other fitness measures
that are used in practice which is
the motivation uh for this work
okay so this motivates um you know this
concept of m estimators
uh which includes a special case uh the
um
least absolute deviation and least
squares regression uh problems
so we define a measure function so just
a function g
from the reals to the non-negative reals
which is symmetric
and g of 0 equals 0 and g is
non-decreasing in the absolute value
of x okay
and we can define the m norm
it's not a norm but i'll just call it
that
of a vector y just to be the sum of g
applied to each of the coordinates of y
okay and we can think about regression
in this
very general context of trying to find
this vector x which minimizes
you know the m distance between a x and
b
and as i said least squares are now one
array special cases right i can take g
to be
the square function for least squares
and i can take it to be the absolute
value function
for um l1 regression
okay so yeah
okay stop me if there any questions
so what are some other um loss functions
that are used uh in practice
so one is the huber loss function which
is the following so the huber loss
function
it looks like least square is near the
origin it's quadratic
but as you move away from the origin it
becomes linear
and it looks like l1 regression
okay so this is nice in the sense that
um you know when it enjoys the
smoothness properties
of l2 squared i mean it's differentiable
at the origin
and it also enjoys the robustness
properties of l1 so as you move away
from the origin
you know it's you're not penalizing it
with the square function you're
penalizing it
just with the uh with a linear function
right and it's uh
you know it's it's smooth it uh it
transitions
uh at some point c from being quadratic
to linear
and there are many other examples of m
estimators and a lot of them do have
this
similar flavor that
they look quadratic near the origin and
they start looking linear as you move
sufficiently far away
so there's the l1 l2 estimator you know
if x is small
then you can show that this thing looks
quadratic and otherwise it looks
linear the same thing for the fair
estimator
there's also this notion of a tukey
estimator which is a little bit more
extreme
so it's quadratic near the origin and
when you move far enough away it just
becomes flat
this can be approximated by moving you
know when you're far enough away you're
you know a very low positive slope um
uh estimator so
these are all quite similar um
so i need to define uh restrict the
class of m estimators a little bit to
state our results
and i'll say that an estimator is nice
if it has at least linear growth
and most quadratic growth
okay so what does that mean formally
so there's some constant defect
depending on the
function used to define the m estimator
so that for all numbers a and a prime
where the absolute value of a
is at least the absolute value of a
prime
we have that uh the ratio of g of a to g
of a prime
is at most quadratic a over a prime
squared
and at least uh linear times this
constant
c of g okay
so an ms minor is nice if it has this
property
you can show convex
function g satisfies this linear lower
bound and this is
quite useful because you yeah
um so often times you want to optimize
convex functions convex functions
satisfy this property
we need it for the analysis so that's
basically
those are the reasons that i have um
so this tukey estimator does not have
this linear growth when you move far
enough away but you can approximate it
by
as i said by a line which has a very low
positive slope
um the motivation for the other question
uh
the other bound so why do we assume that
it's uh most quadratic
so it turns out that any uh sketchable g
satisfies the quadratic upper bound and
let me say what i mean by um
sketchable so this is just an intuitive
definition which is that you can take a
vector
x and you can compress it and preserve
its m norm
okay and you can compress it to a small
number of dimensions
that's what it means to be sketchable so
more formally there's a distribution
on t by n matrices s
you know independent of x for which
for every fixed x if i sample one of
these matrices s
we have the m norm of s of x is within a
constant factor of the n norm of x
okay so um and what we want is this t to
be a slow growing function of
n so s is this you know wide fat matrix
we're taking this
uh tall thin vector x and we're
computing s times x we're compressing it
and we want the m norm to be preserved
up to a constant factor
and uh it's known that um if i have say
uh
you know if this is growing larger than
quadratically
then actually t depends very heavily on
n so for instance if it grows
um as the third power then uh for any
such
uh distribution s i need to have at
least n to the one third uh
t needs to be at least n to the one
third which is often prohibitive
so the way the algorithms are going to
work in this talk is we're going to
sort of do a sketch and solve type
solution where we take a regression
problem
and we compress it and then we solve the
compressed
problem much more easily and
this is sort of why we need this
sketchable condition
for that to work okay
so now with that i can cite our results
so let n and z of a denote the number of
non-zero entries
of your input matrix a to the regression
problem
the first result is the following so for
the huber loss function
what we show is that there's an n and z
of a
log n plus poly d log n over epsilon
time algorithm
which outputs a vector x prime
which with high probability satisfies
the following relative error guarantee
that the huber loss applied to ax prime
minus b
is at most one plus epsilon times the
optimal fitting
uh to the regression problem under the
hubert loss
okay so the time complexity is almost
optimal it's uh near linear in the
number of non-zeros of this matrix a
you need at least that number of you
need at least energy of a time to
achieve relative error
um and then for this uh wide class of m
estimators
uh we also showed the following that
in n and z of a plus poly d log n uh
time we can output an x
prime so that for any uh constant vector
approximation
we get with high probability that for
any nice m estimator
uh ax prime minus b and the m norm is at
most a constant times the optimal
uh fitting in the regression problem
okay
so um it's a very general result for
you know for any nice m estimator and
here the time complexity is actually
uh optimal up to a constant factor
the difference though is it it works for
any fixed constant c
greater than one and um the time here
depends quite horribly on this constant
c so as c
gets very close to one uh this blows up
its exponential in
sort of the distance of c to one uh or
one over that
so so so it only works for a fixed
constant c larger than one
um just to put these results in
perspective
so you know for convex uh
nice m estimators you can solve um
solve them with convex programming right
but these are generally slow
so you know a generic convex programming
solver will give you poly and d time
whereas we're really getting uh time
that just depends on the
sparsity of the input matrix
um and also i'd like to say that in some
sense that our algorithm for
nice m estimators is um is very generic
in the sense that you start with uh it's
universal in a sense that you start with
an instance to regression and you
compress it
and the compression is done in a way
that actually doesn't depend on the
choice of m estimator
okay so after you compress it you can
then decide which estimator you want to
use
and you can just solve you know you can
solve the compressed version in a
different way
for that m estimator
okay so let me briefly go over the
result
for huber which i've isolated here
because i think this is an important
special case and then the general result
for m estimators
okay so how do you solve uh regression
so here is a very naive sampling
algorithm
so i have this you know i'm trying to
minimize
the m norm of ax minus b one thing i can
do is just uniformly sample rows
okay so we can let s be a matrix which
implements this
uniformly sampling of rows
you know it's a diagonal matrix where i
have either zero one on the diagonal
and i throw away the zero rows
i just uniformly sample a small number
of rows say
something that is polynomial in d over
epsilon the small dimension d
doesn't depend on the large dimension n
and i just
solve for the optimal solution in this
much smaller space
it's a d dimensional vector and i just
plug it into my original problem and i
hope i get a good solution
okay so this is a terrible algorithm um
basically because uh you you can't
really achieve relative error this way
you're going to miss very important rows
you can imagine repeating a row
many times and then having another row
and you you sort of need x to depend on
both rows but if you just uniformly
sample you're only going to hit this
repeated row many times so this can't
this can't achieve
uh relative error however there's a
better
algorithm which is also sampling based
but it's based on
so-called importance okay so it's based
on important sampling
of the rows and this is called leverage
score sampling
in the literature so
what i'm going to do is instead of
uniformly sampling i'm going to give you
a much better distribution on the rows
to sample from so this
will work for lp norms so suppose for
the moment
m is uh is just taking the value x
is the function x to the p then what it
says is
there are probabilities q one through q
n so each of these is just a um
a real number between zero and one and
it specifies the probability that you
sample q
i specifies the probability that you
sample the i row of a
together with the ith entry of b
the sum of the q i's is small it's poly
d over epsilon
so if i apply if i if i think of these q
is the sampling properties
and i apply them to the rows of this
regression problem in expectation i'll
get
roughly poly d over epsilon samples
which is small
and moreover um these these
probabilities guarantee that if i solve
this
problem in the sketch space that i get a
uh
then i get a one plus epsilon
approximation to the original problem so
if i
if i sample according if i sample each
row q i independ
each row i independently with
probability q i
and i form this matrix s this associated
sampling matrix
and i solve this problem then i'll get a
one plus epsilon approximation
okay so you know one question is how
hard is it to find this
uh this distribution these qis
so you can actually find all the qis
very efficiently for lp norms
um in near input sparsity time
um just one uh
just one thing to note is here s is not
0 1 on the diagonal as it was
for uniformly sampling uh to make this
an unbiased estimator
you should scale up by one over q i
where q is the property that you sampled
um okay so what are these important
uh sampling probabilities for lp norms
okay so we can first ask what is it for
the standard least squares regression so
what it is is the following
so i have this matrix a this n by d
matrix
and now take any orthonormal basis for
the columns of a
okay then what do i know about this
orthonormal basis
so the squared column norms are all one
well what can i say about the squared
row norms
so these are called the leverage scores
the squared row norms in general you
can't say too much i mean
the squared row norms of course sum up
to d since the squared column norms them
up to d
the squared row norms are also between
zero and one and i just let q
i be the i squared uh row norm
and actually you can show that this qi
is invariant under the choice of
orthonormal
orthogonal basis that you choose
for this matrix a and so if you sample
according to these
then they sum up to d and they provide
this relative error guarantee
okay this is uh uh a known result
and there are generalizations to lp
norms so instead of least squares
regression if i look at lp regression
there's a generalization of an uh
orthonormal basis
to what's called a um a well-conditioned
basis
by descripto at all and it's very
similar in the sense that the qi or the
peace powers of the p norms
of rose in this notion of called the
well-conditioned basis
okay so that's what they are and um
yeah so that's that's how you would
solve regression
where the loss function is um uh
the lp norm and um
so how are we gonna solve uh the huber
regression uh
problem so we can first uh show an
inequality
that foreign for any vector z and rn
it's huber norm is sandwiched between
its one norm
and one over root n times the minimum of
its one norm
and its square two norm okay this is
just by a case analysis of looking at
um this is just the case analysis
um and so this suggests a very natural
algorithm
that what we can do for huber regression
is sample from a mixture
of a distribution defined by the l1
leverage scores
which i just you know i just said that
you can do this for any lp
and the l2 leverage scores which were
these row norms in an orthogonal basis
so if i let qi1 be the sampling
probability of row i
for the l1 and qri2 the sampling
probability of row i for the l2
then i just sample from this mixture of
these two probabilities
and i need to over sample by a root n
factor to compensate
essentially for this loss in the
inequality but it doesn't matter because
what happens is the following we just
get a very simple recursive algorithm
uh so our algorithm for the huber loss
function is the following
you know in the first step we sample
according to these probabilities and the
number of rows
uh decreases to something like root n
times poly d over epsilon
okay and then we just repeat this so we
then recursively solve a weighted huber
um there are weights involved in the
recursion because
you need to multiply by uh one over the
probability that you sample the row
but these weights don't grow too quickly
and
once you know you do the recurs
recursion enough where the
number of rows is less than say n to the
0.01 times poly d over epsilon
at this point the generic convex
programming algorithms become efficient
and you know at this point if i run a
complex programming algorithm on the
weighted huber problem
it'll fit in my time budget of n and z
of a log n
okay so that's the basic idea there um
let me just briefly say the result for
nice estimators
so this is based uh on sketching instead
of sampling
um so uh what we previously uh showed
was that
for l2 regression we can do the
following
if we take our matrix a and we compute s
times a
where s is a random matrix of a very
specific form
so s is a very sparse matrix
the columns are chosen independently in
each column
i choose the location of a single
non-zero entry uniformly at random
and in that uh location i put one or
minus one with
uh equal probability okay so because
it's so sparse you can compute s times a
in n and z of a time
and um what we showed is that if you
take
roughly d squared rows in s then if you
replace a with s times a and b with s
times b
and then solve the regression problem in
this much smaller space
that you get a relative error uh
approximation
and solving it in the smaller space only
takes polyd time
so we build upon this result and for
general m estimators
our sketch uh looks like the following
so it's a block matrix um
what is this matrix so in each block i
have s i times d
i for some random matrices s i and d i
the s i are just independent count
sketches that we saw on the previous
slide
okay they're just these very sparse 0 1
minus 1
matrices and d i is just a diagonal
matrix
okay so um what d i is
is the following it's an n by n matrix
right i'm applying this to
an m by d matrix a d is an n by n
diagonal matrix
and on the diagonal it's um zero or one
and um it's basically what it does is it
just samples
uniformly roughly a one over d to the i
fraction of the
of the rows okay so the top matrix d0 is
just the identity matrix
then d1 is the identity but i zeroed out
uh you know uh all but a one over d
fraction of the
of the ones and i continue this process
to get d
d2 d3 etc and this is
um this is the whole uh sketch
which you know doesn't depend on your
matrix a you just compute
so call this sketch t you just compute t
times a
and t times b and you solve
the regression problem so what did i
what i said earlier about the sketch
being universal is the following
so you compute t times a for the sketchy
matrix t and t
times b and then you can choose any m
estimator
and what you do is you just solve this
uh regression problem
minimize the m norm in the sketch space
and this is very efficient because
the number of rows of t is something
like
poly d times log n right so it's whereas
the original number of rows was n
okay um this sketch
uh comes up in various places uh so it
was used for estimating frequency
moments in the streaming literature
and for embedding earth mover distance
by urban and john
i just want to note that many analyses
of this data structure don't quite work
because
in context such as frequency moments
they sketch a problem and they reduce it
to a smaller problem
but the smaller problem in order to uh
when
when you solve it to try to estimate the
original problem you have to solve a
non-convex problem
so it's very important here that in the
sketch space we're still solving a
convex
problem if the original problem was
convex and this
gives us efficiency and we show here
that it works in the context of
lopsided subspace embeddings which
yeah how much time do i have this amount
of time okay so yeah so
just let me just say one word about
lopsided subspace embeddings which is
that
we can't preserve the the entire column
space of a
so what we'd like to do is for all x
preserve
the norm of ax minus b which is
preserving the norms of everything in
the column space of a
at join b we can't do that but what we
can show is that this matrix t
doesn't contract anything in the column
space of
of a at joint b and for the optimal
vector it doesn't dilate it by more than
a constant factor
and that's enough for the regression
problem it's lopsided in that sense
okay so let me just conclude um
so yeah so in summary we give input
sparsely time algorithms
for huber loss function
and for nice m estimators more generally
follow-up work and other questions so we
have some recent results
for low rank approximation so uh
typically when one does the single value
decomposition
one is interested in minimizing the sum
of squares
of distances what we can do is uh
minimize
you know the sum of uh an m estimator
applied to the distances
this is a much more broad class of uh
low rank approximation problems
um and sort of a meta question that was
a question i had in the
uh in my introduction earlier which is
that there are many uh techniques in
sketching and streaming
uh that have been applied to linear
algebra to
to achieve faster algorithms so count
sketch gives input sparsity time
algorithms for l2 regression uh p stable
random variables such as
uh cauchy random variables are useful
for lp regression
say for l1 regression or more generally
lp regression for p between one and two
um the approach here that we had is sort
of based on what's known as count sketch
plus finding heavy hitters
in the streaming literature and there
are other techniques in streaming which
give rise to
sort of kernel variants of regression
and i think there's there's really a
nice interplay here
and uh that remains to be uh explored
more so
that's all let's thank david
one quick question otherwise i suggest
that we'll take a break until
11 20 and maybe encore and you can
already maybe try to set up okay thanks